[MUSIC PLAYING]
VASCO GOMES: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Vasco Gomes.
I am the Global CTO for
Cybersecurity Products at Atos.
Atos is a global
digital services leader,
generating 12 billion euros,
or approximately $13.5 billion,
of revenue yearly.
We employ 120,000 employees
in our 73 countries.
We announced last
year a global alliance
with Google around artificial
intelligence, machine learning,
hybrid cloud, and
digital workplace.
In these initiatives, we embed
our own cybersecurity product
solutions and cybersecurity
products from third parties
that we leverage to secure
these services to customers.
We have opened three AI labs
around the world-- in Paris,
London, and Dallas in the US--
where we welcome customers to
come with their AI use cases.
We have Google AI engineers
and Atos AI engineers
and proofs of concepts
around the AI use cases
focused on those.
We base our strategic
innovations on six services.
I promise it's the last
slide about Atos itself.
We help customers increase
their application agility.
Our digital transformation
business unit does that.
We also enable SAP on
Cloud for our customers.
We drive more IoT
focused analysis
in terms of connecting the
cloud and IoT worlds together.
We've done on-prem
services for the customer.
Digital workplace
is the fourth point
about collaboration in real-time
on Office 365, G Suite,
and over cloud services.
As I said, artificial
intelligence services
for customers leveraging
Google technologies,
and the one point where
I will focus today
is hybrid cloud for customers
in a private on-prem
and a public cloud environment.
I will specifically
focus on the security
and start with a few concepts
that I believe should be core
and should be the
basis of understanding
between our customers,
ourselves, and the cloud
service providers.
As you see sometimes,
there are now
some customers that are coming
back from the public cloud
to on-prem for their services,
because they misunderstood
the concept of shared
responsibility.
I think a lot of
people talk about that,
so it's getting more and more
in the heads of everyone.
I wanted to speak
about that again
today to make sure
that it's clear.
When we move our services
to have infrastructure
as a services cloud
service provider,
we still are
responsible from the way
we configure our virtual
network, our workloads,
firewalling, the platform,
the applications, identity
and access management.
And ultimately,
even in a SaaS mode,
we are still
responsible for data.
Gartner predicts that
through 2023, more than 99%
of security failures in a
public cloud environment
will be due to a
misconfiguration
from the customer incorrectly
setting up access controls
on packets on a virtual
machine, incorrectly
configuring a web application
firewall, et cetera.
That's where it's important to
focus our security technologies
and security service correctly
when we move to the cloud.
When I say cloud, I encompass
IaaS, PaaS, and SaaS
services, and
making sure that we
know where is our
most sensitive data
and where it's being moved.
We need to identify it and
start if we are not doing it.
If we did indeed
not do it yet, start
to know where is the
most sensitive data.
Even if we don't go to a
full classification model,
at least identify the
most sensitive data.
In order to apply what I believe
is the core security domains
that we are to protect
the data, which
is managing the identities and
accesses of people and objects
that are accessing your data.
When I say objects,
I speak about IoT,
but I speak also about
any kind of machine,
any kind of server
application, API,
that is accessing your data or
requesting access to your data,
and apply encryption to
the most sensitive data.
There is no point-- and
I will show it later--
there is no point in
applying strong encryption
to all your data.
So you should really focus
on the most sensitive items.
Once you have done
that, you need also
to control your virtual network.
And it will be more
and more difficult
as we see that the
boundaries are expanding,
and that when we think about
the fact that we are [INAUDIBLE]
and our business units use
not only IaaS services,
but also SaaS services, like
Salesforce, Workday, Dropbox,
and G Suite, then the new
perimeter of the enterprise
is driven by the
data that is moving.
I don't speak any
more about that.
I speak more and more about
the perimeter of the data
where is the data moving,
and that's a big challenge
to understand.
Once you've set up
your security controls,
never assume that
you are 100% secure,
that nothing will happen.
You still have to really
focus on how I can detect,
and in a timely manner respond,
appropriately to events.
Always key and
understand also which
configurations I may have
missed or may have overlooked.
Then, in order to make sure
that you know where the data is
moving, focus on controlling
the use of SaaS services
and IaaS services by
your employee base
or by your business units.
This is mostly helpful and done
by solutions like CASB, Cloud
Access Security Brokers.
Gartner predicts that by
2022, 60% of large enterprises
will use a CASB, while today
I think it's a proximity 20%.
Understanding the use of Shadow
IT and SaaS by your employees
will also allow you to better
target your security awareness
and identify what new
services are being adopted
by your employees, to
either secure the services
or propose to your employees
secure alternatives.
Once we have said that, what
we mostly have forgotten
is that security, as
an IDC study has shown,
is not only the number one
concern for a public cloud
migration program.
It's also paradoxically
the number three driver
for moving to the cloud.
I see cloud technologies
as an opportunity
to do security better.
We need to shift a
lot of our mindset
and to adopt these
new technologies to be
able to tackle some
concerns or some obstacles
that we are not able
to tackle on-prem.
When I think about
public cloud, I
don't think any about
virtual machines
that we set up on
a GCP environment,
but also about the
possibility to automate,
to use infrastructure as a code
for automatically deploying
our workloads to a CICD pipeline
or an immutable infrastructure.
This is a way for us to automate
the delivery of security
settings, security agents.
Embedding our security
agents and settings
into the templates of our IT
when they deploy new machines
is a way to make sure
that our controls are
deployed consistently.
It helps also in terms
of security habits.
Because if you are sure that all
your templates are configured,
you know all your
protection is deployed.
Once we use these
strategies, and we
move to a more
auto-scalable infrastructure
and focus on total scalability
where on-demand, according
to the load of customers,
we provision new machines,
we will move to a world
where the traditional legacy
static firewalls splitting
our infrastructure
into three or four segments
will not be enough anymore.
So controlling it still will
be critical and important
to control what we call the
north-south communication
from the internet to your
environment, from your on-prem
to your cloud environment, also
from more secured zones that
use internet.
But you will have to ensure
also that you monitor
what is happening between your
machines, your workloads, which
can be virtual machines
or containers, as we
have micro-segmentation.
So enforcing security
controls, firewalling,
intrusion prevention,
packet inspection,
entering and outgoing
of every machine.
And by this leveraging the tags
and labels on your machines,
that are something that has been
already adopted by the DevOps
entities to make sure that
when they deploy new workloads
they know what these
new workloads are doing.
This is an opportunity
for security professionals
to also use that in
order to better automate
the firewalling and the
delivery of security agents.
One thing that we do is
pushing all our partners
and all our security
vendors to make sure
that they adopt unified security
posture, that I will explain
later, which is one central
console to orchestrate
their solutions across on-prem
platforms and public cloud
platforms.
With this central console of
the security vendors being
open to API calls, meaning
that these API calls need
to be secure, by
taking this assumption
we will be able to make
all these solutions
or these vendors
working together.
One of the many security issues
I see in security today, which
is the speed of closing the
doors when an attack occurs,
or the speed of the response
to an event, whether it is
a security event coming from
a log or a misconfiguration
that you have detected.
So doing that and
enforcing that,
we are able to really automate
and orchestrate our security.
It's something that I
will dig in further later.
Also, test your application.
Use application security testing
tools to help your DevOps
understand which
[INAUDIBLE] abilities
they have in the code,
the business code
that the business applications
that they are developing
and open source
libraries they are using.
The application security testing
vendors are adopting DevOps
are connecting or opening their
tools to a CICD tools, Jenkins,
GitHub, JIRA, to be able to
automatically scan new code
and scan code as it's edited.
And most critical within
IT, create a ticket,
but fix ticket in JIRA,
so your developers see
that as a new bug fix for them.
Once we have done all that,
the next step is, from my point
of view, know that your
production, when you have
a four-party solution or a
piece of code that is vulnerable
and you need to
update it, you don't
need to patch the production.
What you need to do is
update your templates,
like I mentioned
earlier, test them,
and then your production
of your environment
will be honored with
these new templates.
You need to ensure that
you kill your existing
workloads in a structured
manner and stuff the new ones
with the new template.
So we don't have to
negotiate anymore,
which is what was one of the
painful parts negotiating
maintenance windows
with the business.
They always say
that they are 24/7.
They cannot afford
for a downtime.
So now there is no more
downtime with this strategy.
You update the templates,
you kill the machines,
and start new ones.
And when you have done that,
you can push the logic forward
and see that you don't need
your machines, your workload,
as they are multiplying
horizontally to be one
single one to be up forever.
You can set an expiration
time, let's say eight hours,
and say that all
your workloads will
expire after eight hours and
your auto-scalability engine
will monitor [INAUDIBLE]
managed instance groups,
will monitor all the workload.
If this workload was necessary,
it will spin up a new one
starting from your template.
You know that your
environment will
be renewed after
your [INAUDIBLE] will
be honored after eight hours.
Of course, this is applicable
only to applications
that are compatible, that are
cloud- native applications,
are compatible
with this approach.
But as we move
forward, that is what
I see-- moving from
[INAUDIBLE] applications
to these cloud
native applications.
When you do that, you will
remove the persistence
of your environment and
make it harder for attackers
to discover your environment
When they start plugging
an agent or a Trojan
on your environment,
it will be removed after
eight hours Of course,
this is only valid if you make
sure that they cannot tamper
with your templates, and your
templates become your most
valuable assets,
along with your data.
So once I did that, this
introduction was really
to focus on your data and
the code, so the templates
and the data that drives your
business and your applications.
And once I said that the data
is the most important part,
to enforce data
security-centric features,
I will focus on two features
that I will point out
now-- identity and access
management, and encryption.
So first, very
quickly, I believe
this is something that is
pretty clear for everyone.
But I will take
it again, which is
how does the Identity Provider,
the IdP, work with [INAUDIBLE]??
One customer, one user,
makes a request to the cloud
environment-- to Google
Cloud or to G Suite,
to GCP or to G Suite--
is presented with a G Suite
login page, login field.
I enter as a log in,
Vasco.Gomes@Atos.net,
and it's redirected to the
identity provider configured
for the Atos.net domain, which
is a third-party provider where
we have federated
our identities with.
Once this is passed to an
identity provider which
makes the request to
the user, presents
a new page to the user, and
the user enters his password,
or enters any other
identification method,
could be a strong
two-factor authentication.
And once this is done,
the identity provider
validates the identity of the
user and his access context,
and delivers a token
both to the user
and the secret to the
cloud service provider.
And the user is then entitled to
present this token to the cloud
service provider,
which can then allow
him access to his environment.
So once we've said
that, and we are--
Atos is a global managed
security service company
delivering services
to another cloud
to more than 200 customers,
large enterprises.
We are facing with
a difficulty, which
is how do we manage all these
complexities of every customer
having his own identity
provider and accessing
a multiple set of solutions?
It could be a
software-as-a-service solution,
like ServiceNow,
TIBCO, Office 365.
It could be an API
gateway, like Apigee.
This is a complexity to
manage and to set up.
You have to set up the
environment everywhere.
And also some providers are
not multiple IdP compatible,
like TIBCO Spotfire.
What we've done is
transformed our solutions
to work as an IdP hotel.
So the customer can still
rely on his own IdP provider.
There are a lot of
them now on the market.
And we don't touch
anything on these.
We just hold for a
while the request.
The feature is called Where
Are You From feature in SAML.
So we do-- when the
365 G Suite provides us
with the authentication, we set
up our Atos Evidian web access
manager as IdP for
the service provider.
And in the customer
environment, we
set up Atos Evidian as a
cloud service provider.
So we insert ourselves
into the chain,
and we enable by
that to be simplified
in terms of management,
in terms of monitoring,
and also for TIBCO
Spotfire-- for example,
it sees only one IdP,
which is our IdP.
Once we have done that, we can
plug our identity governance
and administration solution.
It's a workflow management
certification solution,
which will sell for the customer
information security office
team as a single location to
define all their profiles.
So we are bringing
different profiles,
and they can define for
every role and profile who
from their teams are
integral to this profile.
It could be a Linux
administrator,
SAP administrator.
It could be a folder organizer
or an executive assistant
in there for
collaborative services.
And this is defined in
our central location.
And we are adapting
our profile templates
to be multi-cloud available.
So once a customer
wants to move workloads
from one cloud
provider to another,
do a migration from
a competitor to GCP,
it doesn't change the templates
that we use in our solution.
We just un-provision
automatically
the access rights and
the groups and users
from the previous environment.
And we do the API calls to
Google Cloud Identity, which
is the IAM model of
a Google, to newly
provision the users, the groups,
and access rights in GCP.
So it eases the migration from
a cloud service provider to GCP.
We provide a single
point of administration.
[INAUDIBLE] provides
a single location
where they can see all
of their access rights,
and they will come back on
all of their cloud service
providers.
When you do an audit,
you don't have the time
to go to every one of your
cloud service providers--
should it be GCP, G Suite,
Dropbox, Salesforce, Workday.
You simply go to the
Atos Evidian interface,
and you see who is
entitled to which role
of all your
[INAUDIBLE] providers.
And you have the traceability
of the activities, which
also gives you a single button
where when an employee leaves
the company, you just
go to the console,
remove his access rights.
Or if you have
integrated your IdP
with ours, which
is the objective,
we detect with our IdP that
the user has disappeared
from your directory.
The IdP part of our solution
communicates with the identity
governance administration to
un-provision the customer.
So for example, in
GCP, when you provision
an account in G Suite,
and a user authenticates,
each session is active
for two weeks by default.
So when a user is
removed, he leaves
the company, even if you
remove it from your directory,
the IdP session when
you authenticate,
lasts for 14 days.
So if when you
remove his account,
he has open a session from
his own unmanaged device
or his own laptop at
home, this session
can be still open until 14 days.
One way of enforcing and
removing these sessions
would be to go to the GCP
console or the G Suite console,
and you do a reset which
kills all these sessions.
What you have to do is a purge.
What we are doing here in
the solution is automating.
As the IdP detects that
the user has been removed
from the directory,
we communicate
with the identity and access
management, our identity
governance and
administration solution,
and we do the API call to G
Suite to reset the password
and then kill all the sessions.
The possibilities and the
use cases are endless.
The strings have coupled
web access management, IdP,
and identity governance
and administration.
We provide the single
point of administration.
We avoid when the customer
spins up a new cloud service
provider, he doesn't have
to hook up all his IdPs.
We just do it from the
cloud IAM solution.
And by doing that, we
avoid also the complexity
in a cloud migration of adapting
all your access rights from one
cloud provider to another.
It's very-- the identity and
access management model of GCP
is very different
from its competitors.
So it could be a key blocker for
moving from a competitor to--
your workloads from
a competitor to GCP.
Because you have
to not only deal
with the complexity of
moving your workloads,
but also the complexity
of adapting your IAM.
With this strategy,
you are completely
free from this issue.
I also mentioned earlier
about managing your identities
and access to your data is key.
And in some cases, you can also,
for your most sensitive data,
want to encrypt them.
In GCP, by default, all
your data is encrypted.
So GCP does default encryption.
But this default
encryption, that you
see in the left
of the picture, is
done with their default
key management server.
You have no control, no access.
You cannot revoke
the encryption keys.
You cannot spin up different
encryption keys for different
environments.
For that Google has a service
called Customer Managed
Encryption Keys, CMEK.
It's basically exactly
the same service.
You have the same key
management server from Google,
but this time you
have an interface,
and you have access to the
Google KMS, Key Management
Server.
And you can affect
different keys
to different business
units or different business
applications.
You can revoke keys.
You can rotate keys.
If you have a doubt about
the security leakage,
you can go to the key management
server and revoke the keys.
You have more control.
But still, for some
customers, they
don't want to put all the
eggs in the same basket.
For the most
sensitive data, they
would want to have more
control on the way the keys are
generated and the ways
the keys are stored.
So for that, there
is another option
in Google, which is called
Google Customer Supplied
Encryption Keys.
It's an API of tools
of Google communicating
with your key management server
that you can host on-prem
or on a private cloud.
It enables you to
use your own solution
to generate your own
key management server
to create keys and store them.
When a Google Cloud
Service needs a key,
you have to provide it
to CSEK so we can decrypt
the workload or the data.
When I spoke earlier
about the need
to classify and to
understand your data,
you could not use
all the solutions
that Google gives to you if you
don't know where your data is.
There is no point in encrypting
with Customer Supplied
Encryption Key all your
data, because as we know,
the more control you have
on your keys, the less
compatibility you have
with Google GCP services.
So the default
encryption, of course,
is compatible with
all GCP products.
The customer managed encryption
keys, the version where
you have access to the key
management server of Google,
is only compatible with GCP
application layer encryption
and GPC products--
Google Cloud Storage, the
packets, Google Compute Engine,
the virtual machines,
BigQuery and Dataproc.
And as we speak, Google is
enhancing their compatibility,
but still is not
all the products.
When you go to bring your own
key strategy, CSEK, Customer
Supplied Encryption
Keys, it's only
compatible with Google Cloud
Storage and Google Compute
Engine.
It's a balance between
the trust and agility.
The more trust you have in
the control of your data
and the encryption keys,
the less compatibility
you have with Google services.
But you might, for your
most sensitive data,
for the most critical
data, you might not
need to use all the
Google services but only
specific ones.
That's one thing
we help you to do
is to make sure that
you can set up the best
approach between these
four registry layers
according to the
sensitivity of the data.
One thing that
I've not mentioned
is the encryption tool used.
In all these cases, I have
spoken about the default
encryption and the customer
supplied encryption keys
when you use your key
management's server on your
[INAUDIBLE].
There was a line on top
that is [INAUDIBLE] module,
which is optional.
For greater trust
and greater entropy
and the greater randomization
of the keys generated,
you could generate
them with hardware.
When you generate
a key software,
use a random function of
the operating system, which
is less reliable in
terms of the strength
of the key than hardware
based, but it's optional.
And all that is always using
the cloud provider encryption
tools, so in the case where
you bring your own key
you use Costumer Supplied
Encryption Keys solution
from Google, which is
still a Google solution.
So they still need you to
bring your key at the moment
of the decryption of data.
They don't have access
to all your encryption
keys at all times,
but at the moment
the authorized user
needs to access the data,
the key needs to be provided
to the cloud providers who
decrypts the data and provides
it unencrypted to the user.
So the first step
is, how can we build,
have more control in the
encryption tool itself,
and replace CSEK or CMEK
for encryption of Google,
but rather use your own
key management server
and fob and your own
encryption solution
and not provide the key to CSEK?
Our solution, which is called
Atos TrustWay Data Product,
is a global key
management server
embedded in a hardware security
module that you can host
on-prem or in a private cloud.
In Atos, we can
deliver it as a service
also where the keys are
generated here and managed
and stored in these [INAUDIBLE].
We provide connectors
and integration
to encrypt file systems on
Linux and Windows, et cetera.
We do database
encryption Oracle, DB2,
to MSQL Virtual Machine
encryption, application
encryption, and
tokenization, which
is only replacing
data with a token
and keeping an index
of these tokens.
We also have connectors for
MongoDB, [? Hadoop ?] HBase,
and multiple other services.
Deploying such services on
GCP and using this service,
you can afford to provide
the keys to a provider,
like your legacy,
like Google, and have
a single pane of glass, a single
controller, a single console,
to control all your encryption
on-prem under IaaS or PaaS
services.
In SaaS services and
[INAUDIBLE]---- so integrate,
we have connectors with the
main CASB providers-- netskope,
McAfee MVISION,
[INAUDIBLE],, Blue Coat,
that is now acquired
by Symantec,
and with [INAUDIBLE] encrypting
data in Office 365, SAP,
Salesforce, G Suite, et cetera.
So it is more
specific to Google,
with our private cloud,
the digital private cloud,
which we deliver to customers
with G Suite and GCP.
So what that allows is
for large enterprises that
have deployed encryption
solutions, encryption
strategies for their most
sensitive data on databases,
on veteran machines, on
file systems, what we bring
is a single pane of glass, a
single central console, where
you have a full visibility
on the encryption policies
that have been set up.
So you don't have a discrepancy
over the encryption algorithms
and encryption keys that are
used in an Oracle database
or in your Linux file systems.
You have one single console.
You can see all the
[INAUDIBLE] when you want to.
An example-- [INAUDIBLE]
is considered insecure.
You can remove it from
all your solutions
from one single location.
And you have also
visibility every time
anyone has asked and obtained
access to a decryption key.
This enables better
control, better compliance,
easier audits, with this
central management console.
One thing that I
always put forward
is that when your
security controller fails,
hackers have found a way
through your firewall holes,
have used a zero day undetected
by your IPS, Intrusion
Prevention Sensor signatures,
or web application firewall
signatures, when these
have been breached,
the final protection is have
you encrypted your data.
So as a summary, I focused
on IAM and encryption
because I wanted to
focus on the data.
But these strategies of having
a unified central console
to manage your security
feature or security
solution over on-prem and public
cloud, whatever the solution,
should be applied,
in my point of view,
to all security domains.
For example, there is one
of the biggest security
partners of Google on GCP
is Palo Alto Networks.
For traditional
Nextgen firewalls,
they have this
panorama console that
is a single central
console able to control
their on-prem firewalls,
so physical Palo Alto
firewalls, as well
as the Palo Alto VM
series, which are the
virtual appliances
that you can deploy on GCP.
And with this
central console, you
have availability on all
your network firewall rules,
whatever, via to a network
to subnet, is a subnet on GCP
or is a subnet on your on-prem.
For all security
domains we are pushing
our partners or security vendors
to go to the same strategy.
Whatever is a player on data
loss prevention on firewall,
as I said, on encryption,
every security domain.
So to enhance one thing
that is very important.
It's a central visibility
for your control,
central visibility for
where your data is moving,
and deploying new controls
consistently of real time
monitoring and central
monitoring of your event
from a central location.
This is what we are
building are on top
of just IAM and encryption is
for delivering all security
services on a public
cloud environment, which
is the top part of the slide,
and on-prem, all that driven
centrally by a security
orchestration automation engine
which is delivered from
our security operations
center, able to
orchestrate and automate
the solutions wherever they
are, public cloud or on-prem.
We need to focus
on the data layer.
I focus today on
how I can better
use unseen access management and
encryption to protect my data.
Everything I said was
focused on public cloud,
it is true for on-prem.
We should not forget
that we have also
to protect according
to our model
if we are in IaaS infrastructure
as a service delivery mode,
we have to protect
our applications
containers, VNs, or by the
same individual network.
What we do by this is enabling
our customers to have a better
ability to control data, be
compliant with regulations.
It is one thing to have deployed
the controls or the processes
that allows you to be a
compliant with regulations.
It is another thing to be
able to demonstrate it in case
a security breach happens.
And you will have
to demonstrate it.
So if you take the
example of encryption
and if you have your Oracle
administrators that I've
done correctly their
job that have encrypted
the most sensitive
data, encrypted
the database or the
table at stores your most
sensitive data, but
using an Oracle tool,
you have the same thing for
your Linux administrators
that have done this for
the system, for SAP,
you have done it.
You have all these teams that
have done their job correctly
but in a silo.
And you don't have
a central visibility
on which encryption
algorithms, which
linked keys they are using, so
you will have a long hard time
to go to every team
ask for a report,
look at the configuration to
demonstrate to the regulator
or to any entity to prove
that you are compliant
and that you have set
up these correctly.
Meaning disabled the
encryption algorithm
that are no more considered
secure for example.
I'm repeating it and
its looks of use,
but this central console,
single pane of glass for all
your security features, is key.
And one field that
I see developing
is for IaaS and focusing
on the infrastructure
as a service is the cloud
security posture management
solutions, like Headlock, Dome9.
So Headlock has been
acquired by Palo Alto.
Dom9 has been acquired
by Checkpoint.
You have DV Cloud that has a big
stand on Google Next this week.
Tugboat and OverUs and Cloud
Passage, these cloud security
[INAUDIBLE] management
are delivering
from a single console to API
calls to your environment.
Some are [INAUDIBLE],, some
are API as [INAUDIBLE]
and based on APIs.
They have built a set
of security policies.
They call it internal
controls or policies,
but it's rules and best
practices that they have built,
and they test your
environment to check
if you're complaint with that.
The most used
examples are, do you
have a bucket open in a read
or read/write to the world?
Do you have a virtual
machine with firewall holes
allowing all accesses?
0.0.0/0 any access?
Do these API across all
your if you are multi cloud
or your cloud environment?
For me, these cloud
security [? postal ?]
management solutions will
also open to cloud third party
and will be able to work
as a central console
to control all of your
security controls.
[MUSIC PLAYING]